well you came up with a little bit I
guess what a lot of guys gotta deal with
it now social media yeah like you have
to tell it oh yeah cut the tail end of
it yeah because you know you get done
with a game and then you might get some
media or when you're walking out of the
reading of fans might shout something
but then it's over really or you know
there might be some local news when I
take some heat or some Tanya show 24
hours now it's like dudes are getting on
there checking the instagrams on y'all
[ __ ] game do you can't believe you
missed that and they're paying attention
to uh sorry grantor ants my favorite
player but he's hands down to me it was
time to do in the NBA I love Kevin
Durant when I found out he had burner
accounts I was brokenhearted have you
heard of it uh no no well he had fake
accounts like skip bayless yeah they
take outs and he was chiming back at
kids like kids like you suck you laugh
at it he probably needed a car so it's
different mail or because I don't think
people understand like we all have a
level of criticism but you know he went
from being like be loved by everyone
when his mom was the real MVP and had
the emotional speech where Kevin art
Kevin Durant was you know that like the
poster board for the NBA to the next
season or the our season two were after
that like going to the words in the
world hating him you know we talked
about it on the podcast and to me Kevin
yeah I was like you know it's like
you're Kevin Durant who gives a [ __ ]
about these people like cuss him out
from your phone like yeah why'd use a
burner account and he this this and that
and that he's like I'm still gonna use a
burner can you and I like the fact
because I'm someone that fires back to I
think people think and I'm sure you guys
get it too with the platform we have
people think that they can just say
anything to us yeah we're not human Oh
turn your shoulder be the big man [ __ ]
they're like if you say something's
gonna annoy me enough or disrespect me
enough I'm gonna say it back to me
because I just wish people live I'll
like don't say nothing you wouldn't say
to my face that's how I which they never
would never ever
man yeah just one idea principle it
should be a prince of like just don't
say nothing you wouldn't say you're
giving these dozens of this holy yeah
where they you know how how ain't
concern how stupid you have to be to
fire something at Kevin Durant
way to go dude I'm watching I'm watching
the fights with a bunch of actors a lot
of them pretty famous and stuff and
they're all but we're watching we're
watching Anthony Joshua and Andy Ortiz
fight in D Rouge and we're a fight and
we're watching them fight and these guys
went box in their whole life
and by the way Sugar Ray Leonard is
there yeah now shut the [ __ ] up around
Sugar Ray watch done and I got people
criticizing the fighters so I don't know
they can't align fights of it and to
your point about just like saying
something bad about somebody and we know
a comic who got chewed out by another
comic because he went bad on on her and
for me who that comic goes hey
[ __ ] you can say that [ __ ] to
one and said [ __ ] to my face you
remember you told me this story oh yeah
yes yeah but the point is oh yes the
point I'm not gonna say anything you're
right the combat forum and trash talk
somebody unless I'm will have fun
why don't you think it's just tough for
you know because like I said we give
anybody a voice now and you know you
made it to the highest level
professional fighting you made it to the
highest level in your profession like
it's hard to get really hard it's
because it feels easy everybody to do it
everyone would be really always hard
it's in and that's not just we in any
profession when you get to the top it
takes a lot of work dedication sacrifice
everything but then you give people a
chance to just say whatever knowing got
them well they probably can't even tie
their shoe and you know chew gum at the
same time or can't you know so it's just
like right you know what I love about it
yeah a lot of us J want to be maps you
know chances in their life they see you
live in other people right yeah I I love
when you know one thing I love and I use
just pay attention to is when they
during NBA games will have fans come out
and shoot free throws or make layups or
do some kind of con
during timeouts can't make a [ __ ]
layup air volume free-throws have to
like like three-point line it's like
you're the same [ __ ] people booing
and scream at us telling us and we suck
and you can't even make a layup you yer
see what Deontay Wilder did to troll so
when the you know heavyweight champ of
the world at one time he this guy kept
rolling them kept Rama he's like dude
come to my [ __ ] gym cuz he got like
he's some small white dude who's like
I'll [ __ ] you up if I ever see you have
to I was like come to the gym bro come
to Jimmy dude shows up turn things crazy
though well the dude shows up Indian
state knocks in the [ __ ] out no way yeah
well damn yeah please he kept falling
down but he's crazy this guy's Charlie
his name is Charlie Zelle and selling
off yeah he's completely what was this
really boxers and he's out of his mind
and tries to finalize how crazy is
already got a Samsung flip phone so he's
2014 and yeah you just talkin smacked
him and then shows up he actually goes
and tries to find
if he's going to take his head off dude
he's there a boxed he's not a boxer
nobody is though these guys online none
of them but this guy's actually crazy
and he goes and tries to challenge you
every pro boxer including may with his
father and starts swinging really hard
he's gotten beaten up so badly look
a-here may get the hell out the way Oh
get up get up oh you caught on my [ __ ]
- oh yeah and and people who do not know
Deonte water if you're watching this
he's the nicest coolest guy in the world
so think how bad this guy's been
trolling its lot man people - people
understand that man is you know I asked
Kobe in our interview I just like you
know what are some of the stuff that
stood out from the media or people that
said nasty things to you that stood out
to you and he paused and looked at he
said all of it like I heard all of it
you know me like that [ __ ] hurts you
know we're human we're ready we just
happened to get paid you know a good
amount of money to do something but
we're still human and I think people
lose that you know because we've made it
to the top that okay well they make a
lot of money it doesn't matter yeah
because he's rich it's good it's okay to
do it it's never open what's weird is
like with you or Kobe or Steph Curry and
I can go through a list of guys I don't
see it really affecting them I'm sure
some of you guys see it but then with
Kevin Durant because I love him so I can
it weighs on who like he has the hoodie
up and you tell he's like he's thinking
about them dude you're the baddest
[ __ ] on the coach mm I don't
want to do I won't believe are not
listening to good or bad because I think
the same the same critic the same when
you get you know satisfaction from
somebody saying good things who be
careful because we're all too sensitive
I'm too sensitive the world owes you
much like 80s comics or movies that were
youth the words they're using is people
that lose their mind and it was back him
Nick Nolte and Eddie Murphy I forgot
what movie I was just watching another
what hours and he was [ __ ] this new I
was like oh
got about you know everybody was a
normal dialect and you know amongst each
other in a movie like now people to lose
their mind you know he's pretty straight
you know to mean so I think overall you
know obviously it's a sensitive time
with race and everything but I mean I
just think overall you know we're very
it's just different now you know what I
mean and every respect and love everyone
but we're very sensitive right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]